bonjour à tous nous sommes aujourd'hui
au bord de la loire qu'on appelle le
fleuve royal
long de plus d'un millier de kilomètres
il a inspiré des écrivains des peintres
mais aussi quelques légendes notamment
celle du pont de beaugency
venez on va vous la raconter
[Musique]
longs de 440 m ce pont aurait été
construit en une nuit par le diable on
retrouve cette légende un peu partout en
france
pourtant c'est celle de beaugency que le
célèbre écrivain irlandais james joyce a
raconté à son petit fils et que ce
dernier a édité en france comme tout
touriste il a souhaité depuis paris
visitez le val de loire et ses célèbres
châteaux et il s'est arrêté à beaugency
la finale t il a été frappé par par la
magnificience du du célèbre pont de
beaugency
et il a certainement dû entendre parler
de sa célèbre légende qu'il a décidé de
réinterpréter l'histoire de james joyce
est aujourd'hui la plus réputée et la
plus connue donc elle a détrôné les
anciennes versions
la légende raconte que le diable conclu
un pacte avec le maire est là en échange
du pont la première rame qui
traverserait lui appartiendrait mais le
lendemain
l'édile plutôt malin s'approcha avec un
chat et lui vit dans un seau d'eau
dessus le film traversa le pont à toute
vitesse le diable été dupés bien entendu
le diable a été très mécontents on dit
même qu'il aurait donné un coup de pied
au fond leur âge ce qui aurait donné
cette forme légèrement incurvée haut
pour que vous voyez devant vous on dit
aussi que le chat s'est réfugié dans une
tour ici acquis depuis porte le nom de
tour du diable le pont a certes été
construit il ya fort fort longtemps
c'est d'ailleurs l'un des plus anciens
de la région mais il s'agit plutôt de
l'oeuvre de riches seigneurs
on a des écrits qui nous disent que
environ 150 mme150 5
ce pont était déjà là et ce pot et là à
l'époque où les cires de vos gencives
sont des cires très puissant c'est cette
puissance qui leur a permis de pouvoir
se permettre
j'ose dire
de construire ce pont à cet endroit
parce que c'est le seul point de passage
entre blois et orléans et à cette époque
cela revêtait une importance capitale
parce que jusqu'ici l'économie que l'on
pouvait tirer de la loi était une
économie dans le sens est ouest le pont
a donc servi à transporter facilement
des marchandises d'une rive à l'autre et
a récolté monde et âmes mais de l'argent
via un péage il a en tout cas bien
changé depuis car plusieurs fois rénové
à cause des guerres et des crues de la
loire et pour aller plus loin sur les
légendes autour de la loire nous sommes
justement sur la loire avec michel
marronne vous êtes compteur
saltimbanques vous faites des balades
contées avec la maison de la loire et du
loir et cher
alors pourquoi il ya si peu de légende
autour de la voir il y en a si peu parce
que tout simplement ils n'avaient pas de
veiller sur la loire en campagne des
veillées à partir de l'automne il ya
moins de travail dans les champs les
gens se rassemblent ils ont froid et il
ya toujours un colporteur quelqu'un qui
passe raconter des histoires sur la
loire il n'y avait pas de veiller les
mariniers va travailler tout le temps
sauf quand il y avait des embâcles ont
été gelés pouvais pas naviguer
bon et puis quand il y avait beaucoup
d'inondations
donc là effectivement il ne travaillait
pas mais elle est plutôt à l'estaminet
que de se retrouver en famille
pour écouter des histoires blanc qui
avait pas dit veiller sur la loire même
s'il n'ya pas de légende
il ya quand même des personnages qui
revenait par exemple diable ça le diable
c'est un personnage qu'on rencontrait
dans les conversations dans les peurs
les légendes naissent des peurs
forcément donc le diable était quasi
omniprésent le passeur par exemple qui
passait d'une rive à l'autre a été
presque un diable il passait de l'autre
côté les gens qu'est ce qui se passait
de l'autre côté et c'est même s'il y en
a un auquel autres légendes circulent
sur ce fleuve dans cette région il y en
a une autre à vareilles juste à
l'endroit de la centrale où là la loire
fait un coude
un ace et il était donc très très
difficile de naviguer
donc il y avait beaucoup de nos bras du
naufrage et les mariniers disait qu'il y
avait une femme qui apparaissait soit en
amont ou en aval du coude en fonction du
bateau le marinier les mariniers était
pris par cette jolie jeune femme qui
apparaissait avec les difficultés de la
de la navigation prof
il faisait naufrage c'était tout
simplement une vengeance car cette femme
s'était noyé et elle s'appelle
s'appelait jeanne et donc on appelle ce
s la grande jeanne merci beaucoup michel
et merci à la maison de la loire et du
loir-et-cher est assez mariniers pour
cette belle balade nous on se retrouve
demain pour parler des mégalithes